what have you learned he said no
mistakes about humans
doing annotation because I assume humans
are uh there's like a range of things
they're good at in terms of clicking
stuff on screen it's not
how interesting is that to you of a
problem of designing an annotator where
humans are accurate enjoy it like what
are they even the metrics are efficient
or productive all that kind of stuff
yeah so uh I grew The annotation team at
Tesla from basically zero to a thousand
uh while I was there that was really
interesting you know my background is a
PhD student researcher so growing that
common organization was pretty crazy uh
but uh yeah I think it's extremely
interesting and part of the design
process very much behind the autopilot
as to where you use humans humans are
very good at certain kinds of
annotations they're very good for
example at two-dimensional annotations
of images they're not good at annotating
uh cars over time in three-dimensional
space very very hard and so that's why
we were very careful to design the tasks
that are easy to do for humans versus
things that should be left to the
offline tracker like maybe the maybe the
computer will do all the triangulation
and 3D reconstruction but the human will
say exactly these pixels of the image
are card exactly these pixels are human
and so co-designing the the the data
annotation pipeline was very much bread
and butter was what I was doing daily do
you think there's still a lot of open
problems in that space
um just in general annotation where the
stuff the machines are good at machines
do and the humans do what they're good
at and there's maybe some iterative
process right
I think to a very large extent we went
through a number of iterations and we
learned a ton about how to create these
data sets I'm not seeing big open
problems like originally when I joined I
was like I was really not sure how this
would turn out yeah but by the time I
left I was much more secure and actually
we sort of understand the philosophy of
how to create these data sets and I was
pretty comfortable with where that was
at the time